je cours avec ma bière cours avec les
armes je fais tout le contraire fait
tout ce qu'on a envie de prendre l'air
je vous allez apprécier non je peux
rester sincère j'ai battu haas où j'ai
vu c'était ouvert envie de prendre l'air
je vous ai des amis me jean jeu quand
même en hiver je prends les limaces
si je prends pas le vsr si je le pense
je m'ennuie envie de prendre l'air je
veux aller à draguignan
je vous reste à faire j'ai vu quand tu
as des bus était ouvert j'ai vu aussi le
terme demandé de prendre l'air le goût
d'aller à l'eau
rien qui nous conduit pas traverser la
rue moncoutié insomniaque et jure que je
n'ai pas dormi envie de prendre l'air je
veux aller à bientôt
bon je pense que ça met du piquant à la
très belle simulation démoniaque il faut
faire des choix une envie de prendre
leur jeu mais d'aller à sa guise les
options de dialogue avec eux un tas de
cochonneries la boîte de prod taxe pas
comme si j'en avais envie de prendre
l'air je veux savoir où je vis ça comme
une attaque qui a envie de prendre l'air
de nos adresses à rouen
[Musique]
là
bah
[Musique]
je joue visa mais je paie tout le monde
a envie de prendre l'air je veux aller à
bientôt
je veux rester une affaire j'ai vu quand
tu as été ouverts j'ai vu aussi le
sermon qui doit prendre l'air chez bosal
est roi ce qu'on veut en hiver je prends
le menu mais je ne peux pas le dessert
je vous avais amené l'île aux genevois
des concerts sur les berceaux jeu mais
les acteurs ont respiré à léo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'en ai fait six morts qu'elle doit son
père
chantonnay six mois
oh
c'est fait
ma chance
il se vend
le banc
[Musique]
gfr
non